wir haben die fotografie natascha ruf in
ihrer stille begleitet diese stimme die
sie jetzt hören es nicht meine ich weiß
auch nicht wie meine stimme klingt denn
ich bin seit geburt gehörlos sagen wir
dies ist meine innere stimme
bestelle ich etwas und das personal ist
gestresst kommt es schon mal zu
missverständnissen
hier herrscht zum glück eine entspannte
stimmung
ergo es ist absolut still
ich höre mit den augen einen
unwiederbringlichen moment visuell
festhalten
das ist meine leidenschaft
ein foto ist ja etwas stilles es gibt
keine bewegung keine ton jeder mensch
verbindet etwas individuelles damit
interpretiert es anders mich
interessiert was die menschen in einem
bild sehen welche geschichte es ihnen
erzählt nicht nur ein bild das ganze
leben nehmen wir ja individuell war
jeder baut sich seine eigene welt
hörende orientieren sich mit ohren und
augen ich verlasse mich